delante del parlamento georgiano un
puñado de militares Pro Europa se han
vuelto a reunir Como cada tarde desde la
invasión a gran escala de Ucrania por
parte de Rusia
estamos aquí porque nuestro país está en
peligro nuestra decisión la decisión del
pueblo es Europa pero nuestro gobierno
nos lleva hacia Rusia Georgia luchó
durante mucho tiempo 30 años para no
hacer nada más que pequeños avances Y
actualmente estamos retrocediendo no
queremos retroceder hacia Rusia
[Aplausos]
el pasado 7 de marzo la adopción de un
proyecto de ley copiado del modelo ruso
desató el caos según esa legislación las
ong que recibieran financiación del
extranjero pasarían a adquirir la
condición de agentes extranjeros ese
mismo día miles de georgianos salieron a
protestar delante del parlamento la
policía dispersó a los manifestantes a
punta de granada a saturdidoras cañones
de agua y gases lacrimógenos Después de
tres días de protestas el partido en el
poder retiró el proyecto de ley para
evitar una escalada de la violencia Ese
soy yo ahí el tipo con el gorro rojo
no quería que esa mujer se cayera quería
sostenerla defenderla y ayudarla
leván es productor de vino Este es el
lagar tradicional georgiano donde se
aplastan las uvas con los pies la
primera vez que salió a protestar fue
durante la Revolución de Las Rosas tenía
13 años en ese vemos entonces el Pro
occidente mijaíl sacasbili había subido
al poder actualmente el expresidente
está encarcelado y su estado de salud
sería crítico según levan el proyecto de
ley sobre los agentes del extranjero fue
la gota que derramó el vaso
estaba furioso quiero que Georgia sea
parte de Europa mis ancestros también lo
querían y está establecido en nuestra
Constitución es un proceso totalmente
Irreversible ya hemos vivido en carne
propia lo que es Rusia no sabemos muy
bien nadie lo sabe mejor que los
georgianos y los ucranianos
a pesar de que el proyecto de ley haya
sido retirado ante la presión en las
calles para los georgianos La amenaza no
ha desaparecido el 24 de marzo la
ministra de asuntos exteriores alemana
analena verbook viajó de visita a
tibilisi sentados frente a frente el
Primer Ministro irakli y Gary bashville
le reafirmó la voluntad de Georgia de
obtener el estatus de país candidato a
la Unión Europea y sus por alcanzarlo
sin embargo ese mismo día delante del
parlamento no acusó a Rusia sino a
Ucrania y a la oposición georgiana de
querer empujar a Georgia a la guerra la
verdadera amenaza para nuestro país es
un complot dirigido contra nosotros el
plan de una ucranización de una segunda
línea de frente en nuestro país este
objetivo de las autoridades ucranianas
se lleva a cabo en coordinación con la
quinta columna
la quinta columna un enemigo interno
cuyo objetivo sería desestabilizar el
país En beneficio del extranjero un
discurso conspiracionista calcado de la
propaganda de Moscú durante su
conferencia de prensa diaria delante de
los periodistas georgianos
hiraclicobagitze jefe de jorjan Dream el
partido en el poder no tuvo más opción
que dar una respuesta hay alguna
posibilidad de que ustedes cambien sus
discursos políticos velados con respecto
a Rusia porque no hemos obtenido
respuestas claras para saber si Rusia es
nuestro o no nuestra línea política es
pro occidental en cuanto a Rusia somos
pragmáticos tenemos una retórica
adecuada somos pragmáticos para mantener
la Paz en este país
pero los vínculos del partido en el
poder con Rusia serían más que solo unos
discursos favorables respecto a
moscúnica
incluso desde la cárcel nos da esperanza
y motivación para luchar
en una de las tres cadenas de televisión
de oposición georgianas y ekesi su
presentadora estrella
su fundador el Pro europeo mica guaramia
cumple una condena de tres años y medio
de cárcel por un caso de malversación de
fondos que la sociedad civil georgiana y
algunas ong como amnistía internacional
consideran político es un ferviente
opositor de piscina y vanish Billy un
oligarca que hizo fortuna y se entrenó
en política en Rusia elegido Primer
Ministro en 2012 y 2013 fundador del
partido georgian Dream y vanish Billy
Afirma haber abandonado la política pero
los georgianos consideran que es el
dirigente informal del país
desde el principio el objetivo fue
deshacerse de los medios libres y
críticos
es una figura central en los medios
tenía mucha influencia
su encarcelamiento mandó un mensaje muy
claro de que este gobierno estaba
haciendo todo lo posible por sabotear
nuestro hacia la Unión Europea
antes de que desapareciera del ojo
público eca entrevistó a ivanish Willy
en varias ocasiones según ella aunque él
siempre coqueteó con Europa y Rusia la
guerra en Ucrania fue decisiva
el primer ministro dio entonces un
discurso en el que reprendía a Ucrania
por no haber hecho todo lo posible por
evitar esta guerra
ese día para nosotros quedó muy claro
que iban a escoger un bando y que ese
bando era Rusia
ahora un nuevo caso despierta la
indignación en Georgia un hombre de 21
años se enfrenta una condena de 11 años
de cárcel tras las manifestaciones
contra el proyecto de ley sobre los
agentes extranjeros